>> One of the common misconceptions of that phrase, nature versus
nurture, is that it seems to imply one or the other.
>> The question really should be, how much of
a role does each one play in different traits?
>> Exactly, maybe it should be nature and nurture.
>> I like that. Because it implies that both are important and
we just need to determine which one is more important for different traits.
>> Exactly, this is really important for
complex traits like. Risk for breast cancer, or
even traits like height.
>> Well, are there examples of traits that are caused
by multiple genes but not much of an environmental influence?
>> So you mean like a really big
nature portion and not a very big nurture component?
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> There are a few, and one of them
is eye color. Eye color's actually what we call
a polygenic trait. A polygenic trait is a trait
that's controlled by multiple genes with very little environmental influence.